where's the agreement to disagreement
between you and jordan peterson on this
i just talked to jordan about this
um because you're very clear
it's it's kind of beautiful in the
clarity in which you lay this out
um i wonder if jordan has arrived at a
similar kind of clarity what have you
have you been able to draw any kind of
lies between the
way the two of you
see religion yeah so there was a video
released
i think like two or three weeks ago with
jordan and myself and jonathan paul who
i haven't watched that one yet yeah and
it's around this question lux he's
basically sort of making
um he's putting together an argument for
god i mean i think that's a fair way i
don't think he would object to me saying
that and um
and jonathan paul is also a um
well jonathan is a christian it's
unclear what jordan is um and jonathan's
work is on symbolism and different
mythologies and christianity yes
especially neoplatonic christianity
which is very important
um i have a lot of respect well i have a
lot of respect for both of them i have a
lot of respect for jonathan but in in
in my participation in that dialogue
you can see me
well repeatedly
but
but i think everybody including jordan
thought constructively challenging sort
of the attempt to build a theistic model
and i was challenging it from a
non-theistic perspective so i think we
don't
um
agree in
on
certain sets of propositions
but there
was a lot of there was also a lot of
acknowledgement um and i think genuine
appreciation on his part and jonathan's
part of the arguments i was making so
they believe in the
maybe the presupposition of like a
supreme being that not believe but the
the not not believe but
they see the power of that particular
presupposition in uh uh being a source
of meaning i think that's
relatively clear for me with jordan
jordan's a really complex guy so it's
very hard to just like pin to my best
sort of
understanding
yes i think that's clearly the case
for jordan it's not the case for
jonathan
jonathan is remember i said i was
talking about modern atheism and theism
jonathan is a guy who somehow
went into
icon carving and maximus the confessor
and eastern orthodoxy and has come out
of it the other end as a fifth century
church father that is nevertheless being
rightfully so found to be increasingly
relevant to many people i think so he's
deeply old school yeah i think he has he
and i especially because neoplatonism is
a non-theistic
uh philosophical spirituality and it's a
big part of eastern orthodoxy he and i i
i think
he would say things like god doesn't
exist
what you're a christian right and then
and he's being coy but he'll say well
god doesn't exist the way the cup exists
or the table exists the same kind of
move i was making a few minutes ago
he'll say things like that he he will
emphasize the no thingness of ultimate
reality the no thingness of god because
he's he is he's from that version of
christianity
um what you might call classical theism
but classical theism looks a lot more
like non-theism than it looks like
modern theism
that's so interesting
yeah that's really interesting what what
about um
is there a line to be drawn between myth
and religion in terms of its
usefulness in
man's search for meaning so here's where
jordan and i are much more actually all
three of us are in significant agreement
um
i said this in my series but i i want to
say it again here
myths aren't
stories about things that happened in
the deep past that are largely
irrelevant
myths are stories about perennial or
pertinent patterns that need to be
brought into awareness and they need to
be brought into an awareness not just
or primarily at the propositional level
but at those non-propositional levels
and i think that is what good mythos
does i
i prefer to use the greek word because
we've now turned the english word into a
synonym for a widely uh a widely
believed falsehood and i don't think
again if you go back even to the you
know the church fathers i'm not a
christian i'm not advocating for
christianity right but right neither am
i here to
attack it right but if you when when
they talk about reading these stories
they'll right they think the literal
interpretation is the weakest and the
least important you move to the
allegorical or the symbolic
to the moral to the spiritual the
mystical and that's
where right so they would say to you oh
you know but how is i how is the story
of adam and eve true for you
now and i don't mean true for you in
that relativistic sense i mean how is it
pointing to a pattern in your life right
now so there's some sense in which the
telling of this mythos
becomes real
in connecting to the patterns that
kind of uh captivate the public today
sure so first so you just keep telling
the story i mean there's something about
some of these stories
they're just really good at being sticky
to the patterns of of each generation
yes and they they'll stick to different
patterns throughout time they're just
sticky
in in powerful ways yes and so we keep
returning
back to them again and again and again
and
it it's important
to see that some of these stories
are recursive they're myths
about one particular set of patterns the
their their myths about right not not
like not just the important pattern like
you get the you know jordan's stuff
about
there's heroes and myths are trying to
uh
make us understand the the need for
being heroic in our own lives one of the
things i'd like to put in counterbalance
that is the greek also have myths of
hubris
right that counterbalance the heroic
right but then
there are
myths
that
are not about those deeply important
patterns
but they're myths about
religio itself that the way we're
religio means to bind to connect the way
relevance realization connects us and so
the point of the myth is not notice that
pattern or notice that pattern and
notice that pattern it's
notice how all of these patterns
are emerging and what does that say
about us
and reality and those myths
those myths
i think
are genuinely profound
you